David gross is a theorist he works on
string theory which hopes to unite
everything in physics in one grand
mathematical model Robert Laughlin is
passionate about experiment he
challenges gross and the three students
they meet to come up with ways to test
their ideas about the universe
I wonder if you folks could talk a
little bit about falsifying early
universe models is there more than one
of them that will account for facts as
you see them now
it depends exactly what you want to
falsify so inflation so far I would call
it a parody because it's still it is
still looking for a new entity or a more
developed theory to be embedded in the
inflation is an early phase of evolution
of the universe in which the universe
expanded exponentially rapidly inflation
essentially is for the layperson what
the Big Bang gets when the layperson
thinks of the Big Bang actually the
thing about at this moment of incredibly
fast expansion of the universe
I guess Laughlin was saying you know is
it really what falsifiable in that you
know do we have a series of models that
we can then take out one from the other
due to certain experimentation that's an
incredibly predictive theory but with
very few parameters which fits the data
very well what are the alternatives to
inflation there are no sensible that I
know alternatives to inflation in the
sense that I described it of saying that
the geometry underwent inflation I mean
you would be interested in knowing that
actually some of them competitors they
have failed the text these observations
really can falsify models there have
been for example bouncing universes
beyond inflation scenarios so it seems
that they are really very valid tests
yeah well let me be devil's advocate the
cases I know of explosions are unstable
the hydro dynamically unstable when when
things are changing scales as a result
of a phase
which is what we're talking about you
get structural instabilities in them a a
gap to example would be popcorn now in
the case of popcorn it would be very
difficult to work backwards from the
measurements of popcorn to figure out
what the popcorn looked like before you
popped it you could make some models and
certain models would fit the popcorn
better than others but they mall might
could be completely wrong because you
didn't have enough [ __ ] a backwards
time to see the kernel of the popcorn
now that's sort of what I'm getting at
when we talk about falsifying models and
you really have enough experimental
constraints to really tell inflation it
is not a phase transition inflation is
not it absolutely is its Norma's amount
of heat coming out of that background to
face it is an explosion David you're
you're completely bribed it's not an
explosion because it's not higher than
an amical but there is energy pushing
the thing outward coming from the
equation of state of the matter of the
vacuum and Bob this is very different in
general relativity you can sit on the
top of the hill and you're pushing the
universe outward nothing it's a totally
in a sense stationary there's a filling
you know perfectly well this is a card
trick what it's actually doing is
blowing up okay yeah no you arguing
against the big bang of course I never
argued the first rule of theoretical
physics has never argued with data okay
the question is constraining models and
one of the things that I've become very
worried about in modern physics with the
tendency to under constrain model of
experiment so we say we've got the model
in situations where there are many
that will give the same experimental
result and in this subject as far as I
can tell as an outsider the models that
I've seen are all highly under
constrained so we're on we're on task
here so the thing I was trying to bring
up here is the issue of the interaction
of ideas with experiment
so experiment plays a dual role for a
theorists it gives them essential clues
and hints and partial information on
which they can construct a solid
foundation for their theories and then
it tests the predictions they make and
which is the the way we've learned to
discard that ideas so it's absolutely
essential after the Big Bang and the
initial expansion of the universe
inflation matter cooled down and
radiation escaped the afterglow of this
radiation is all around us it's known as
the CMB or cosmic microwave background
radiation the CMB
is a snapshot of the universe in its
early days when it behaved like what
physicists call a blackbody a black body
emits radiation in a characteristic
spectrum measurements of the CMB show
that it matches the blackbody radiation
spectrum very closely and this says
Grouse is compelling evidence for our
big bang theory of the universe we have
to write in evidence that that micro
exactly is the most perfect radiation 10
demise but nobody can absolutely it is
the best black body radiation curve ever
the error bars on the curve easily small
of itself ya know it's ten to the minus
five there is nothing in on earth that
has ever been a better blackbody where
you know I have a hard time with that
but I haven't looked so I don't know
maybe I think two or three orders a
night let the record show that I do not
believe this man and how I look about
like a little bit okay a bottle of booze
the wine what is it what is it no no
tabletop experiment has ever gotten a
uniformity of blackbody radiation okay
that was a case of one so he was
surprised I think by by that claim and
he thinks that in the laboratory one
could do as well and it's my
understanding that one can't even come
close in the laboratory and they had
this bet where he said you know I don't
believe that it's possible to make a
black body which is you know more fun
than the CMB which is of course the bet
that he's going to lose because it was
experimental it was experimental kind of
verb that he says you know no we can
make it we can do it better you know the
experiments can be manufactured in some
way that will basically improve on it
let the record also show that whenever I
lose a bet I pay I trust the same as
with well the record can't show that yet
that would be a cost I have lost best
afford a but I have a lot of bets on
supersymmetry very very bright people
can easily delude themselves and happens
a lot so you have to learn the skill of
how to tell yourself know that the
experiments are not agree with me and
that even though I'm very proud of
myself and I'm an egomaniac because we
all are I have to say that wasn't right
and we have to go back to the drawing
board and get it right you want to
propose
things that can be proved wrong or
you're not the real thing right so but
what you're saying is that until we
don't take the experiments we should not
produce models that maybe in the future
will be falsified or not no no people
are perfectly free to spend their time
the way they want no but I mean you
think it's useful to do it or not
thinking about what might be is always
useful all of us do it is part of a
discipline okay I mean I'm one of the
worst offenders a victim and I have I
have the trashed papers to prove it
but this has to do with your your desire
to find what's fundamental and one of
the lessons you learn here is that you
sometimes just have to wait until a good
experiment comments even though you
probably you might have figured it out
sure sometimes there's more than one
answer and there's just no way you can
figure it out by pure logic because
because things aren't the same I would
like to return for a brief moment to
string theory as an experimentalist of
course I would like to know how can how
can i how can I test it when when will
there be a proper test part of the
problem is the string theory isn't a
theory oh yeah no it's the framework the
existence of extended fundamental
objects that are pull that are stretched
out by the universe is the only direct
signal of string theory I can easily
imagine at this point it would help to
have a theory and we've learned that
string theory the quantum field theory
are really the same thing and we don't
understand them and so we're learning a
lot about the theoretical structure but
it still unfortunately still a framework
and not a specific theory what I would
like to hear from string string theory
and very soon is these are the
experimental things this is how it
manifests itself in our world because
that's when I think it turns into to
real physics so I would have preferred
an answer saying that yeah we were on
the verge on
finding it and within a couple of years
we will present you with our recipe in
the near future I think the best hope is
is still the l8 thing because we have a
good chance there of learning a lot of
new physics and any clue and you know is
about incredibly valuable I mean my wild
hope would be somebody would see some
cosmic strings and we could see the
cracking of cosmic strings and the
gravitational radiation coming from
those cracks but but the real hope is
that we will learn a lot from the eight
seed from the supers the nature of
supersymmetry multiplets and breaking
and that that will appear while I'm
still around to do something about
several days later when the five
physicists joined a boat trip they were
still arguing over who won the bet
well no I have to wait till I get home
to check but I think he should pay up
now we actually have here three
references right and what I say is those
three constants are measured to ten
significant figures on earth therefore I
win the bet it is
wait stop this remind me of Chris I know
you also measured the de principle of
detail balance to better than before
anyway it depended a lot of ways okay
there I should win the bet no you should
okay you should win the better horse
understand each other now and you you
and you know if if there is an
assignment he wants it wine or my
lawyers
you